it's time for screen junkies movie
fights what in the world welcome to
movie fights hashtag movie fights live
we're doing it and doing it and doing it
right I want to give a shout out to
hashtag Owl nation
hello ala nation and we've got some
exciting competitors in the house some
of the best and there's some rivalries
maybe some grudges are gonna be settled
maybe new grudges will emerge let's meet
our combatants first off this is not a
title defense but he is the reigning
movie fights champion also the Schmo
down singles champion he is dan the man
merle dan what's going on brother I feel
weird how I'm used to Billy produced me
out of my seat I think Jack Shipley can
produce some sort of graphic that will
tell you this is the most successful
seat so Billy yeah there you go I'm
trying to give you a more miraculous win
today in the underdog seat you're
welcome
Billy is playing puppet master and I
made the seating chart Dan good luck in
that new seat so Han I'm looking forward
to this
you know you need handicaps in this cuz
you're too damn good at movie by Stan
fighting just to fight you know just to
play the game you are yeah it's nothing
you are movie fights purist this man he
is no stranger to movie fighting and
he's no stranger to the Schmo down you
know him as one of the titular schmoes
collide are all over the place welcome
back to the show mr. Kristian harloff
happy to be here guys thanks for having
me it was it was funny because I was
just saying as I this morning on my cute
show that I do fire live I was on there
this morning and I said said about a
month ago I wanted to come back to movie
fights I'd missed a and done it in a
while and I have nothing but respect for
obviously for not only movie French
champion there's no doubt champion that
adventure I'd love to test my hat
against him as the champion yeah if I
can earn it if I can get there so I'm
gonna take those fights and wait to see
what happens so I get today waiting for
Billy to say this is who you're playing
you're playing me and Dan and I'm like
okay I guess I won now you guys just won
nice to see you harloff catch on the
road but if
if you win today that's a great resume
builder for a title shot well you're in
the bad seat so maybe I'll get looking
yeah it's a that's pulling a tough draw
on your first one back also I'd swallow
you really I mean there's a lot of cool
exciting stuff going down with the Shema
down all the time all the different
incarnations and iterations but there's
a big event coming up please yeah we've
been going on the road a lot we sold out
in New York and in two days obviously
when Dan won the belt back and we are
gonna be we're going to Chicago April
13th 800 people and the shamone on
live.com you'll get tickets but yes
March 23rd at the Globe Theater downtown
Los Angeles the free for all which is
our version of the Royal Rumble it's
about 40 competitors all going head to
head to head to head the last person
standing gets a shot at any title that
they want I never know it was coming in
there are tickets available left and get
the Schmo down live.com about between
four to five hundred people will be
there and it's just going to be it's a
crazy time it's a lot of fun
amazing yeah I've been to one of those
I've competed in those it is and it is
insane and it's always cool when like
you get like a table full of heavy
hitters and then they all get knocked
out or something like that yeah crazy
stuff happens market Drako not for the
best Motown players around as well yeah
that's a great moment
good times Christian awesome to have you
back brother happy to be back and this
man is doing double duty he's uh he does
the producing well yeah yeah I thought I
was doing you guys a favor by taking the
kind of bouncy sinking seat but I guess
by the way Joestar booked this episode
and I put things in order of who gets
their answers in first so you got yours
in first okay
at first seat I'm an amazing producer
right makes it make sense to somebody
Billy Billy biz Billy Patterson thank
you for being here ready to throw down
good to have you across the table and
deciding these fights will be myself and
in place of the Dan cam Lee of the ride
and ridin ridin dirty
we work at the chat want us to do rad
tool but I think that's a good I like
ridin dirty ride and right what's going
on hey just see you hey great to be here
yeah I'm be fact-checking it's a fact
that I'm having a good time but that
come off organically that's what I was
open oh yeah
came off thank you I've learned ahead of
time smooth as a dolphin open mics all
across outside of restaurants bothering
people as they walk away Ryan thanks
rolling it down the fact-check chair you
know and we have our social media
ambassador Daniel Redford yes I am the
social media ambassador so as all of you
know we do have polls that go up on the
YouTube those polls are used as
tiebreakers or other breakers in case it
just seems like the judges aren't able
to make up their mind the way that that
poll works is that once the initial
arguments have been presented the poll
answers will go up you can vote all the
way up until I start giving my decision
and then it's done sorry guys that is
when the poll and they'll still be open
but it no longer counts but I still love
you all so I will be on the hashtag
movie fights live on Twitter and you
guys always have really good other
answers ultimate takes the dankest of
dank memes and so go ahead and get
active in that because if I like what I
see I might shut you out on the show
heck yeah
yeah maybe a corgi or even a shark or an
owl so once again the first player to
four points wins the top two players
after the first three rounds will move
on to the speed round and then speed
around to anybody's game give me down
three oh and make a furious comeback
fellas what do you say we start this
dog-and-pony show this jte please drop
that sick ass package
it's main event
[Music]
Thank You Thor alright so first question
of today's movie fights here it is so we
assume that we've all seen Captain
Marvel yeah I hope so otherwise I ask
questions I'm a little tougher so it's
time to settle this who is the most
powerful character in the MCU who's the
most powerful character in the MCU and
we'll start with player number one Dan
very tough decision but I went with the
victor of the last Avengers movie the
one that we just got a new trailer for
today endgame we're in the endgame
because of one person and that person is
Thanos Thanos is the most powerful
person the most powerful character in
the MCU
infinity got well first of luck with the
Infinity Gauntlet obviously untold power
power over time power over reality power
over just about everything in the in the
universe but not just the Infinity
Gauntlet Thanos is a powerful person he
is a ruler he has ruled over untold
numbers of space he's ruled over armies
he is ruled he has commanded literally
tens hundreds millions of people under
his rule and he's got power over the
universe really because the entire
universe in the MCU from the The
Avengers
through guardians through infinity war
and through endgame the universe has
ultimately been on the run from one
person and that person is fan OHS power
is not just might and strength power is
influence power is reached and Thanos
has more power than any other person in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe alright
Dan coming in with the mad Titan Thanos
Christian what do you got well I mean I
was gonna take that Oh Stannis was the
one I thought at first but then I said
the problem with Thanos is that yeah you
can talk about the gauntlet but the
problem is that it's it's toast now all
the all the stones are gone so he's not
really you can't you can't use this
anymore plus the fact his drive is kind
of gone he's sitting on a farm he's
chilling out he's relaxing he's not he
doesn't have that drive and he doesn't
have the the drive that he excuse me the
drive that he had to really dominate the
universe now Captain Marvel on the other
hand is two men by the way anyone who
hasn't seen Captain Marvel should
maybe pause this response away because
it's gonna have to has to be spoilers
for my argument so captain Captain
Marvel is the first phone call that Nick
Fury makes when he's about to he's he's
he's disappearing so you're gonna call
the person you think is gonna be able to
save the universe especially when you're
the guy that was running shield you call
Captain Marvel we can see why she has
part of an affinity stone that is lodged
inside of her body she doesn't need a
glove to do it there were things that
she did and she's tapped into her powers
now now it was the first half of the
movie she's still learning she's neo now
she's neo she is she knows how to use
that matrix she knows how to use every
bit of her her ability she has shown
that I don't know I'm watching that
movie and I said how do you stop her she
has all the powers of she's as strong as
Hulk she she's as fast as anyone inside
of any of the Avengers she she could
beat all the Avengers by herself at this
point and without that gauntlet I don't
see how if Thanos can stand next to her
even with an army she she no one even
put up a sweat against her maybe she can
put up a sweat against anybody fighting
at the end of that film Thank You
Christian
Billy so I'm going with the
self-proclaim strongest Avenger I'm
going with the god of thunder himself
was that an Australian accent by the way
I'm freaking out over here but I'm going
with Thor because Thor first of all
Titans in this Marvel Cinematic Universe
they're not really gods now Thanos I'll
give you he's a strong powerful guy
maybe the Brock Lesnar of space but he
is not he's not a God like my man Thor
my man Thor much like Captain Marvel was
so powerful that his dad tried to
channel his energy his power through his
hammer and then he found out if you just
unleash the beast baby you got a stew
going and on top of that Thanos has the
entire gauntlet he's given it he's
cranked that thing up to 11 and Thor
without even thinking about it just
throws his axe down Thor's weapon is
more powerful than all of fan OSes might
combined it's Thor a hundred percent all
right let's see this triple team battle
royale match happen though guys I want
to say about Captain Marvel I think
purely there's just not enough game
of Captain Marvel we can't conclude that
she's the most powerful because we've
only seen her in one situation and
statistically Matt speaking she only has
one power of the six power so just by
math I would give it to Thanos over that
at least he's got the power of six she's
just got one he doesn't have the power
of six anymore this burnt out once he
doesn't know that we don't notice you
suck we do know that we thought we don't
know that doesn't work anymore we saw
that it was completely first of all it's
not at the full capacity and you're not
gonna be able to beat her if you're not
speculation we don't know that well my
speculation is correct now when you have
as far as when you looked at it if they
show they did a close-up shot on it the
fact that it was obvious smoke was
coming out plus the fact he thought his
game was over he was sitting back
relaxingg his whole point was to wipe
everybody out he did that he's done his
his like I said the beginning his drive
it's over it's not there anymore he's
not as hungry as he was but for is a
good argument but the problem with Thor
is that we've shown before that he's
he's kind of weak-minded he can be he
can be he absolutely can be thrown off
of his game from us from emotion
Captain Marvel has shown that the exact
opposite I have Captain Marvel has shown
that she can go she can endure any
personal tragedy whatever it might be we
don't need enough game tape we had
enough because at the very end of that
movie you had enough from one movie who
is going to be able to beat her at the
end of Thor when you saw Thor doing all
of his powers whatever it is like okay
there's more movies to show but this
guy's capable of she showed maximum to
the fact like again like I said again
captain I'm Nick Fury needed to call her
and they needed to show how are we gonna
do this only need Captain Marvel we know
that Captain Marvel is essential to this
movie so why is she there to make it
she's a plot point the end of the
trailer you show her because this is the
person that's going to save the question
isn't who's the best strategist do I
think that the war should have gone for
that of course but that doesn't change
the fact that Thor can wield something
that a no one else can because he says
the power alone would kill you he can
take on the blast of a full star he is a
god and he can he's the only thing in
that entire movie that actually repels
Thanos vendors are going down left and
right all you'd have to do is give
Captain Marvel one good Power Stone
click and she's down for the count
Thor how do you know
how do you know because he took out
every other Avenger Thor was the only
one that went toe-to-toe and actually
repelled the might of all the infinities
he didn't he didn't write these Santos
he wounded Santos and ultimately it did
not stop nothing to do with power though
does charge make a stop and shadows came
out on top he won the question is and
who had the best strategy for taking
down the other character the question is
who's the most powerful Thor a hundred
percent if it was strategy Stannis wins
again because Thor did not come out on
top and infinity war strategy is part of
power strategy Santos had a strategy to
get to get his ultimate goal done and
ultimately he accomplished it and not
and some people would say like oh he
didn't say he didn't strategize very
well because Loki failed and you know
and then Ronan failed well he exacta
drew venge on those who failed them and
then said ok if the non direct approach
isn't gonna work then as he said in the
movies I'm gonna do this myself and he
did but the other thing that I want to
bring up with Thanos as well is when
everyone's talking about captain
Marvel's powers and Thor's powers and
Thor's weapon and the Infinity Gauntlet
as a weapon that is one aspect of power
but there's also another reason why
Thanos succeeded and the Avengers failed
it's the quote that he says infinity war
the hardest choices require the
strongest wills at every single turn we
have seen all of the Avengers fall prey
to a fatal flaw it's what it's what
allowed Thanos to get out of a pretty
sticky Jam that he was in which is that
star-lord is a very emotional person and
in the heat of the moment he gave over
to that emotion
Captain America gave over to the fact
that we don't trade lives was that a
very upstanding thing to do yes was that
the best strategic decision know and
that's why fan OHS won not only his
Thanos exerted control over everyone
else in the galaxy everyone else in the
universe he's the only person that has
been able to exert that same control
over himself over his own weaknesses
over his own flaws the Infinity Gauntlet
didn't get fan owes the soulstone his
ability to make the hard choices and
it's a terrible choice and it results in
half of the life and the universe
disappearing
he made the hard choice he defeated even
those things inside himself that have
defeated all of the Avengers at some
point and their villain
pride vanity ego love whatever it is
Santos is the character that was able to
do that and that's not something that
you know the problem the problem the
Thanos that we're not talking about here
today even though yes he's a master
strategist he was the being that was
able to get all the stones and harness
those but we're not talking about it's a
hero he was almost he was beaten he was
beaten he was but stupidity by a
star-lord absolutely stupidity is what
happened there because he was done it
was over and he was at you could see
that Rey a regular human being dr.
strange described magical abilities
obviously but they took it took a bunch
them to do it but he was defeated he was
he was absolutely been defeated then he
would have lost when he was - is you
talk about master strategist if he was a
master strategist he wouldn't have given
Loki an infinity stone to go get another
infinity stone end up with zero Infinity
stones so if you're talking about what a
great leader he is it's like dude you
you keep talking about like I'm gonna do
this myself
but then I'm gonna have my other guys go
get the other what I don't hear is why
Captain Marvel isn't I hear a lot of his
much because Captain Marvel to me is the
one once again because you look at what
she did from a military background or
what she able do was destroy multiple I
have seen people box for one time and
knowing that they're gonna be champions
from their performance of what they were
able to do in the ring that night didn't
win a hypothetical heavyweight
championship he had to at some point get
in the ring and fight and Captain Marvel
has not yet done that against the kind
of competition we see a game tape but
you knew my spicen was gonna be able to
hang with those people and you know the
cap tomorrow was gonna be able to hang
you know I mean everybody in this table
knows Captain Marvel but is she the most
powerful idol against a handful of Kree
soldiers and she destroyed one ship at
least guys like that thousands of years
yeah just like Thor mowed down thousands
of Hellas troops at the end of but is
enough but no one was calling for when
when there was they were in their
standalone movies and no one's calling
for well they're in this movie this big
movie the end of the movie who do they
call they're calling Captain Marvel for
a reason they could have called anybody
else but for they're calling her because
they know that she is the answer she is
the one that can do it you know tomorrow
because Nick Fury doesn't know who else
is gone and there's literally one thing
he can do which is to call Captain
Marvel he knows
drats pager to one person he doesn't
have the four pager that he complained
he's been in movies with these people
for the last whatever amount of years it
is he's got direct contact to all of
them he called cap tomorrow because he
saw a Captain Marvel could do he saw the
amount of power that she had because she
did take down the ship
she didn't take that ship by it like
just oh he's calling because he's the
last resort if she was so powerful he
would have called her when New York was
happening and ended that in three
seconds instead he saw that he had a
Thor instead and that was just fine
powerful he didn't he was that she's and
I don't know if we changed cursing on
this show no we try to stay fairly clean
okay did the OS moment if you will that
is that is what Thanos was and because
like I said it was between him and
Captain Marvel those were the two but
then I just thought about him sitting on
that farm with his arms folded he's
retired he's living in Hawaii right now
he thinks it's over he's right now
because he achieved he achieved the one
task that everyone and this not only
does everyone say in the university that
this wasn't possible
it was the most opposed person in the
history of cinematic Union go ahead and
all this at your final phone danos face
down every single Avenger individually
and collectively as a group and still
one he took the hardest shot that Thor
had and still survived
he took the hardest shot that every
single Avenger had and still survived
that's not just strength that's not just
the Infinity Gauntlet if we're talking
power he has the ultimate weapon he can
wield the ultimate weapon we don't know
what the power of that is yet we don't
know how much the power that still
resides in him but beyond that he is the
man in the Cinematic Universe or the
Titan who wiped out half of the
universe's life that is power that is
real power he effected the biggest
change in the history of the universe
how does that not make you the most
powerful person in the universe it's not
just about what power you had it's about
the power that you currently have he is
a ruler he is a Titan he is a force to
be reckoned with he is a feared man he's
feared there's power in being feared
Thanos is the most feared man in the
universe and he's even even been able to
conquer his own weaknesses which is
something that Thor has definitely
fallen prey to multiple times and
Captain Marvel first of all we agree we
don't know enough about what she can do
there's a lot
potential there but she's also coming
into this fight coming back to earth who
knows how long it's been for her who
knows how she's gonna integrate into
this team for all we know there could be
some weaknesses that Thanos can't
exploit inside of her she certainly is
influenced by an infinity stone
he has Infinity stones in his possession
we don't know what kind of influence
that could wield power is not just
strength power is not just the damage
you can do power is the will that you
exert over others Thanos has the
strongest will Thanos has the most power
and he's the most powerful being in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe thank you Dan
Kristian your final thoughts fear is a
power but it's it's it's also a very
irresponsible power because you're not
looking cuz you can get you can get
irresponsible with it by you don't know
who else is out there he doesn't know
about Captain Marvel so he can be lazy
because he thinks it's over you've got
to be looking around at all times and he
hasn't been because what I think is more
powerful than fear is respect and I
think that Captain Marvel has tons of
respect from so far to say this D from
the people that she's been working with
thus far we know that but as far as does
she is she battle-tested do we know
she's gonna be able to do it we know
it's at least 130 years by the time we
see her twenty something years by the
time we see her and she's off helping
civilizations move to other planets she
is going to we know that she's gonna be
fighting wars with with the Skrulls we
know that she's gonna be doing all of
these different things do they say said
as much she has to protect nations who
do you want doing that the most powerful
person that is out in the galaxy that is
able to set forth a kind of
responsibility and and then like I said
I'm gonna keep going back to it you call
someone not because you just happen to
have their number on pay on the page you
call them because you know they can
fight the fight and that it's worth it
because it's your last call before
you're going you want to help your
friends you call the person that is the
most powerful it's also why she has that
smirk on her face when that when Thor's
axe comes flying by a buyer because she
knows it's also why your most powerful
character looks at her nose immediately
because he doesn't do this a lot with
anybody he looks and he goes I like this
one because he knows she can hang and
probably could whoop his ass too Thank
You Christian Billy I'm not gonna say
that you guys didn't choose powerful
characters because you you most
certainly did but my care
Thor has what your characters has but
more of it
Thanos he's a big dude he kicked the
Hulk's ass with no help
guess who kicked Hoke's ass and movie
before but was stopped before he
finished the job Thor did it
you're saying that Thanos is he's got
the power of being this leader of making
the hard choices guess what
Thor was a leader and he had to make the
hard choice of blowing up his entire
home to save his people and lead his
people to safety you talk about Captain
Marvel has this ultimate power that she
can that she can use to to stop a ship
I'm not doubting that she does but what
I'm saying is we've seen Thor have the
same power we see him storm on to the
battlefield of Wakanda when all hope
looks to be lost and with one bolt of
lightning even the playing field if not
completely turned the tables
your guys's characters are very strong
but they are not a god Thor is powerful
as a leader he's powerful just as a
creature he's powerful with the tools
that he has the only one that can stop
the full power of Thanos his entire
might and and that's and if he can stop
the whole gauntlet I'm sure he can stop
someone who has 1/6 of that gauntlet
Thor is a God he's the most powerful
time all right
wow that was some damn good Marvel talk
you guys I was fun to listen to
I want shows Kevin Feige
answer or the Russo brothers Ryan what
do we got in the fact zone alright a
couple of things here I don't think this
necessarily should decide who had the
better argument but Kevin Feige did
comment on this while promoting for
Captain Marvel said in a sound bite
interview I got the full thing here that
Captain Marvel is she's one of those
powerful characters in the comics and
will be the most powerful character in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so that's
what they were hoping to establish when
they were making her promoting Captain
Marvel who knows what the motivations or
if now that he's promoting endgame he
would also be like actually that us or
whoever they want to know but that was
the most recent thing that Feige is said
about it
Kristen said the stones are gone or
burnt-out
I don't know if that's a hydras insured
they definitely wanted to show that the
gauntlet or something was damaged and
not right after he did the snap and you
could still see it when he's sitting
over there the Sun but I don't think
there's any than anything confirmed that
there's actual damage to the to the
stones they must work to get him out of
there because he uses it to get out
right and so that day no sad
there was someone was saying that there
in the chat that he they know sends Loki
to go get the tesseract so it's just one
my infinity stone but the mine stone was
in the scepter and he was using it and
we can assume that I think that they
understood that so he did give Loki a
infinity stone to then go get one and
then the last thing is that if you ask
the Quinn jet or Tony Stark according in
Thor Ragnarok he would say that the Hulk
is the strongest avenger and obviously
that was very comedic when Thor found
that it wasn't him Jeff Ryan thank you
thank you for enlightening us with some
facts this is a this is a real good
throw down you guys I enjoyed listening
just like as a fan hearing all of your
theories but so it came down to two for
me Christian I thought you had a strong
argument I feel like they really did get
you with it not enough game tape thing
although I mean I love where you were
coming from and I think it may very well
be established that she is as strong or
stronger or more powerful than anyone in
the universe also I love that picture of
just talking about like Thanos his
burnt-out gauntlet and him sitting on
the farm I felt like it kind of reminded
me like some kind of weird bye
agra commercial like yeah I'm not what I
used to be but for me it came down to
Dan and Billy and man I mean I I felt
like the obvious one was Thanos but then
Billy like had with just a strong tail
the tape for Thor and Thor as a leader
Thor's had to make hard choices but at
the end of the day I had to go back with
Dan because what happened where are we
right now in the scheme of things
even though Thor gave Thanos a run for
the money at the end of infinity war
Sano still came out on top he and April
he was able to enact his vision so I got
to go Dan
Ryan where are your thoughts on this I
think I'm gonna go Dan as well I think
while there is a lot of different jobs
going to try to discount each of the
three choices I think still at the
opening closing arguments dancing he had
the best definition of power and all the
different ways that he shows it and so I
thought that had the best argument right
on Dan gets the point
Danielle can you tell us where the poles
at all right well so with 45 percent of
the vote we did have Thanos 36 percent
for Thor Captain Marvel with 18 percent
some of the other names that were thrown
out Scarlet Witch hella Doctor Strange
Dormammu and ghost the cat and Stanley
by like No hell yeah
good constantly if anyone said Stanley I
don't know that would be hard thought
about holy verse fight yeah that's a
whole nother conversation it's not fair
for one person
yeah all right good stuff so Dan takes
the lead one to nil to nil Christian and
Billy looking to get on the board here
is question number two okay speaking of
Thor Taika Waititi will direct the pilot
of Apple's new Time Bandits series by
the way if you've not seen Time Bandits
Terry Gilliam it is one of my favorite
movies of my youth such a fun romp a
time traveling good time okay so new
Time Bandit series coming from Tycho Itt
what 80s movie would you most want to
see Tycho ITT reimagine what 80s movie
would you most want to see Taika Waititi
reimagine and it's question number two
we start with player number two
Christian all right for me this is an
easy one because it's something that
I've been very passionate about it's a
movie that I've wanted to see for a long
time but it needs the right director in
the right tone and that's Flash Gordon I
think that Flash Gordon was a movie in
the 80s that tried to capitalize off of
the Star Wars fame and I love the flood
the Flash Gordon of the 80s but it's
incredibly cheesy and it falls apart as
soon as it begins although I still love
it
I think what Titan could do with this is
you could add the amount of humor but
infused with a nice fantasy sci-fi film
that we can see because what I want to
see him do is start the beginning of a
new trilogy a new saga a new series of
films I don't want to see something that
has already been connected to other
films or something that I know another
director has made and done successfully
because this is this is a property that
is screaming that it is screaming to be
remade because of what look George Lucas
wanted to make Flash Gordon but he
couldn't he couldn't get the rights for
it it couldn't do it so he made Star
Wars and you know thank God he couldnt
get the rights for but if we can get the
rights to take away let's see him do it
because we also know that he can play in
that world he's directing an episode of
the Mandalorian and he knows that well
we knew we saw what he did we info
Ragnarok which was a great space
adventure and I think that to have him
bring together these new planets to to
bring forth a villain like Ming the
Merciless it could be really incredible
again we know that he can pull in very
serious moments we know that he can do
the humor but we also know that he can
paint the picture of an
the galaxy and I think Flash Gordon is
perfect room all right Christian with
Flash oh okay sorry I had to do that
Billy what do you got so I'm going to
choose the chronological start of the
Indiana Jones series Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom I think it's
interesting that Disney has acquired the
Indiana Jones brand and they've kind of
sat on it and I think it's because
they're not a hundred percent sure what
do you do with that and I think with
Temple of Doom when you look at that
original trilogy it sticks out like a
sore thumb a little bit I you know
Spielberg and Lucas have both said it's
kind of not their favorite they were
both in dark places at the time there's
some stuff that definitely kind of is
questionable today there's some there's
like a little bit of like gross-out
humor that doesn't work and the short
round thing is weird and Willie Scott's
terrible but I think if you take someone
like you know if you tell me I'm making
a new Indiana Jones they're like I don't
know you can't tackle with TVs director
you go I know I'm listening and I think
that he could do he could really capture
the like he did in thor ragnarok the
humor of an action hero when he's not
necessarily always winning showing the
human side of it which is why we love
Indiana Jones Billy thank you Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom around the
Hornet Dan yeah I was a choice it's not
a movie they don't necessarily have a
problem with it's just something that I
would like to see him as he seems to be
doing in the era of Time Bandits which
is a movie that has a great cult
following is reimagined and it's movie
that I rewatched recently and that's
beetlejuice I love beetlejuice I love
the Tim Burton Beetlejuice Michael
Keaton is great there's so much that's
great about this movie but watching it
again I was looking at it and I was
saying I wish that we could approach it
not Beetlejuice goes Hawaiian and all
these dumb sequels that have come up
over the years but there's aspects of
the film that aren't really explored
that I would love to see in the hands of
a new director specifically the fact
that most of Beetlejuice takes place in
the house with Alec Baldwin and Geena
Davis and the new family casted O'Hara
and it's really funny and then four
maybe five or ten minutes of the film
you see this other side of the the the
afterlife and it's like this world of
like drudgery and sand monsters and I've
always wondered like what
what exactly is going on there because
you're there for a few scenes and then
you go back to the house and you see
what's going on on earth I want to see
the world of Betelgeuse through Tyco
white TVs lens but I want to see more of
the other side I want to see more of
where do that where do these
bio-exorcist and ghosts live the
ridiculousness of the fact that you work
an office job but you're also a skeleton
or like you know a guy who's half cut in
half and I think that you have a lot of
room for some real absurdist humor in
there and that's what Tyco YTD does he
does absurdist humor really well he has
talked about I think you can you don't
have to completely refute what Tim
Burton did and say like well it's gonna
it's gonna look all CG and stuff Taika
Waititi has shown a lot of interest in
things like stop-motion animation and
really innovative and interesting ways
of storytelling and I think that if you
it's not just another shot in a movie
that I don't like I think it's a real
reimagining of the universe in the sense
that we are taking a base of what we
know and saying let's see more of that
let me see let me expand on that and see
more of that world in a way that's not
that's not sort of trying to wipe away
something in the past but really add to
what is already there all right three
real different choices fight it out guys
I think Jumanji and Halloween has proven
that it's it's I think it's a little
better to instead if you can if you have
some pretty solid instead of remaking
the solid one to continue onto lore and
maybe retcon the ones that didn't work
right both beatlejuice beatlejuice
worked and beetlejuice the first one
it's a Tim Burton imagination film it is
it is clearly Tim Burton's vision I
would love to see his version of the of
the sequels I think I think everything
you're saying about in the death after
that yes but I don't need I liked what
happened to Lydia I liked the way
everything that they did with it with
the music and and with Michael Keaton
you basically have to retcon Michael
Keaton's whole thing up top you could
bring them back it's it's possible but I
think that what you do with that is a
sequel now Indiana Jones the problem
that you run into there because I would
also love to see his version Indiana
Jones the problem is you run into that
Han Solo situation all over again and
it's like you've got to recast Indiana
Jones as the young version because you
could do a sequel if you wanted to
either have hair
and Ford back in it cuz I'd like to see
his version of Indiana Jones with
Harrison Ford now but if you go back and
you do that then you got to recast them
then you got to find the right one then
you get into that whole Ehrenreich thing
again and if that happens then you sink
another property but I reject the
premise that that was like the thing
that sunk so low I wasn't hurt but it
hurt I think that there's a lot of
factors that made solo what it is but I
think look I think had someone like a
Taika Waititi maybe jumped on solo that
would have liked the the Tyco would TD
brand itself I think elevates the
premise or the project and I think with
Indiana Jones like I'm we've just run we
pretty much run up the clock on Harrison
Ford so I think you have to reimagine it
and I think there are elements of temple
of doom that are really great but they
don't really work I think the short
round thing is a little strange to me
that Indy like kind of has this like six
year old kid but imagine it's like we
reimagine a little bit and Taika Waititi
is playing almost like a chord like
character that's a sidekick someone
who's a little bit more relatable
someone that brings the comedy that can
bring the humorous elements because the
best parts of Indiana Jones movies are
the parts where any and a Jones I don't
know I'm just making this up as I go
along which was very much the tone that
we saw him do with thor ragnarok and
that's what gives me confidence that he
could do that with Indiana Jones this is
like a complete franchise reboot it's
not taking tipple of do I mean saying
like this movie specifically I want to
reimagine this movie you're basically
saying like Indiana Jones has done in
Taika Waititi would be good to leave the
new franchise and that's fine but it
doesn't only have much to do a Temple of
Doom and yes it is dark it's very dark
and it's very different from Raiders of
the Lost Ark and it's very different
from Last Crusade and that was the last
Indiana Jones movie that was ever made
just those three and so what I love
about Temple of Doom when I sit down to
watch Indiana Jones rate is the Lost Ark
and Last Crusade are both very similar
in tone they're both not see movies
world war ii you know they share a lot
of DNA
I like the Temple of Doom is in the
middle I like that the tone is different
I like that it's not three movies that
are exactly the same I know the spoon
wearing Lucas have said that they think
maybe that they went too dark and that's
their right as artists but my right as
somebody who likes to watch the trilogy
is I've always liked the fact that you
have this movie in the middle or if you
want to watch it
is over yours too
really no one is clamoring for a like we
need to get beetlejuice up and running
again up and running again Jones but
we're not quite sure how to do it we're
not quite sure what we want out of an
Indiana Jones the minute you say Tycho
YTD is gonna do his take on an Indiana
Jones movie I guarantee you that's when
fans get back what you just made my just
made my point as far as the second you
say Tyco what TD is the second you say
that because of what he's done so far
people go wait what
I would much rather him do something
that you said that maybe not all people
are looking for because the second he
says Flash Gordon well what was Flash
Gordon and then the media comes out and
they go it was the thing that was
instead inspired Star Wars and it is him
going to now be able to build a lot more
he doesn't have to worry about fans
going well who are you gonna cast as
Indiana Jones you can give a nice nice
juicy we recently flex those muscles we
already tried to reboot Flash Gordon as
a TV series and Freeman and crappy song
no one gives a crap about Flash Gordon
it wasn't Taika Waititi doing it for
some reason even working anymore that
did there's no a Flash Gordon problems I
saw Flash Gordon was made at a time
where Star Wars had just come out a few
years earlier the Star Trek franchise
cinematically was very young you did not
have the overload of sci-fi like you do
right now you mean as you said he's
already done Thor Ragnarok the name of
the that our honest trailer name for
Thor Ragnarok was flashed thordan
because that's essentially that was his
Flash Gordon movie it's very much the
same tone of a set in space he had the
same kind of crazy ruler the Emperor
Jeff Goldblum for me that would be
diminishing returns that would in a way
be the least interesting thing Tyco YTV
could do because I've seen him do crazy
space comedy already and and and what
and crazy visuals and as always be
compared to Thor man no that's a scene
that's taking away from what he does
because that is that's pigeonholing him
going he can't do more than what he does
what he has done beautifully in all of
his stuff whether it's television
whatever it might be he is able to set a
new tone to show you oh wait a minute he
did that that was a drama oh wait a
minute he did that was science fiction
that was fantasy that was that was a
horror he's able to do it all and
because it's not Flash Gordon is not
just a goofy comedy like Thor you would
be able to tell if the world just
because it's in space
I think that's that's ignorant to be
honest we because I think what you can
do a space fantasy a space opera it
would be his space opera and we're gonna
see him play in that I already said that
it with Mandalorian but Flash Gordon it
did come that movie by the way was done
is the first one's done like our 30s but
the 80s one didn't know how to do it the
same way you're talking about they
didn't they couldn't crack the code in
the 80s and they couldn't crack the code
into television because I don't believe
they had the right people with the right
vision this is a guy who has proven time
and time again he has the right vision
he is a great writer and he can set up
an entire franchise this movie the same
way I believe the Masters of the
Universe can be a franchise this could
be a franchise and Taika Waititi should
be the guy that's leading I also want to
talk because we haven't talked about
Betelgeuse solar so let me just get my
thoughts on that I'm with you where I
feel like 50% of that movie is the
performances and 50% is the Burton
vision and I think if you take the
Burton vision out of it I don't know if
Beetlejuice really works that well I
think that there's a reason why we
haven't seen another Beetlejuice since
that one is because I feel like that's
pretty self contained that is a moment
of time that is a Tim Burton stamp that
is one of his pieces and it's left there
I don't maybe there are other concepts
to expand upon but if you're talking
about a reimagining I don't think that
it would have worked had it not been for
that crazy vision of Tim Burton but this
is a real but it's the whole thing is
it's actually pitched a reimagining of
any of this meet - my I literally
pitched what how I would do a
reimagining of a story the whole point
of the Temple of Doom is what could I do
to make Temple of Doom current what
could I do to update it what could I do
to fix some of the things I think you I
think you take out the element of the of
the little kid and I said you replace it
with a more comedic Taika Waititi I
think you replaced Willie Scott instead
of being this terrible damsel that has
just nails on a chalkboard I think you
make her a little bit smarter I think
you make her a little bit more edgy like
a Margot Robbie I think that you update
some of the humor in there that doesn't
work anymore
I think you take the concepts of the
temple and I think you take some of the
elements but I think you update it for
today's audiences and refresh Indiana
Jones because you're sitting on a
property that's worth billions and
why take all that time and money to
recatch it to take an existing movie and
recast everything recast the three
leaders ready to change a bit of the
humor and also change that just make a
new idiom don't let [ __ ] here's the
final go ahead and dress your final
thoughts please final thoughts I'm
saying they already doing an Indiana
Jones sequel they already working on
that so to go back and reboot template
do them right now it seemed kind of
counterproductive the overall mission of
what they're trying to do just kind of
reiterating my thoughts with Tim Burton
and agreeing with Bill what Billy said
too is that Tim Burton when you look at
that particular there are movies that
when you look at something you know who
directed it you know why and that is
what Beatle just was for Tim Burton and
I think that yeah you could do it for
Tiger would may he could make it work
but why would he want to why couldn't
you take something like a Flash Gordon
to where what you talked about reimagine
it you take some of the whole it starts
off as an alien invasion movie on earth
and it's terrifying it could be any
shown he could be terrifying you could
do a war the world's type thing
and you don't have to make it some
cheesy thing where the guys in New York
Jets quarterback he's somebody else he's
the East he's someone that Ben runs into
Dale they have to they run into zarkoff
they get into the spaceship and they
find themselves on this other planet and
Ming the Merciless is not Jeff Goldblum
by any stretch of the imagination he's
more so Palpatine than anything else and
if you see what he's able to do and you
see the destruction that that this
Emperor has caused you could really do
something amazing and terrifying and
bring forward one of the best villains
of all time and I think Tyco is the guy
that can do it it's and I don't think
there's I don't think there's ever a
time it has a Star Trek fan I'm shocked
that you said that there's too much
science fiction I think that science
fiction is never too much I think
there's so much more opportunity for
science fiction and science fiction
fantasy and I think there's not enough
good science fiction fantasy and when
you have a guy that did thor ragnarok to
say well he's already done that he
shouldn't do another one that's silly
you have a guy that has just done and
shown that he can do this and give us
great science fiction fantasy he doesn't
have to do the same movie he can do
something completely different let him
do it and let him do it with a property
that inspired Star Wars thank you
Christian Billy yeah just to to
reiterate my point the question was what
film from the 80s would you want to
reimagine I would have loved to have
said just Indiana Jones is a blight
blanket statement but I couldn't so I
chose the movie that I think that you
could actually
rework now and again
talking reimagining we're not talking
you know Gus Van Sant's shot-for-shot
psycho here I'm talking taking the DNA
of what that movie was the sore thumb in
that trilogy and using it as a launch
pad you update the characters you update
some of the humor you update some of the
characters and then you take a franchise
that people are already loved they are
already clamoring for it but they don't
know what they should do with it next
you're sitting on a dynamite of just box
office and then the minute you say Taika
Waititi is gonna reimagine Indiana Jones
for a new generation the launch pads
there I think with beetlejuice I think
again 50% of that is is Tim Burton I
think if you strip Burton from the
beetlejuice it's not gonna feel like
beetlejuice anymore and I get it I get
that's the point of like a reimagining
but I think that actually would just
shine a light on why the first
Beetlejuice worked because 50% of it was
from the imagination of a kid that
wasn't hard enough when he was a child I
think with Flash Gordon I think we've
tried to do Flash Gordon a couple of
different ways I don't think that Flash
Gordon is an IP is gonna move the needle
I've already seen Tycho @td shoot his
load about what he would do in a space
opera situation with a hero with a big
strong hero like a Flash Gordon I've
seen him flex that muscle I want to see
him flex another muscle for Disney with
a Nana Jones thanks Billy
dan the reason that bill just excites me
is a reimagining is that it is it is
truly that it is adding taiko ITD's
imagination to something that already
exists I think that the arguments are
both Flash Gordon and in Asians of the
temple do have more to do with wiping
out the bad parts of something instead
of adding imagination to the good parts
of something and that's what I want to
do here with Beetlejuice yes there's a
lot of Tim Burton that's involved with
Beetlejuice but if you say we're gonna
take elements of that and you bring
Taika Waititi style to it and you said
isn't that what a reimagining is is
somebody coming in and saying like
here's a corner of the world I'm gonna
add my style to this I'm gonna add to
this mythology I'm gonna add some
elements of this instead of just saying
like I didn't like Flash Gordon and so I
am just gonna go through I don't think
he's gonna rip the heart out of Time
Bandits for Apple I think he's going to
take a great a great foundation
bring his self to it and tell a new
story and just both of these pitches
seemed like when I say too much sci-fi I
mean the too much sci-fi exists
necessarily it's just that in the 30s
years since Flash Gordon came out there
have been so many sci-fi sci-fi films
Star Wars films Star Trek films thor
ragnarok i know you don't like the
comparison but there are similarities
that have drawn on the things that Flash
Gordon was drawing from I just don't
think it's as original as it was 30 35
years ago and Indian Jones on the Temple
of Doom I'm like I get what you're
saying but like I know that you answer
Temple of Doom to sort of pitch what you
wanted to do but like what you pitched
was more of like taiko a kidneys
restarting the franchise the entire Nana
Jones franchise more so than reimagining
Temple of Doom and I think with a
reimagine film you want to leave some of
what's there and I think you get that
with Beetlejuice time all right
good throw down a lot of interesting
cause Ryan take us to the fact zone all
right
the only facts I could really see that I
don't want to make sure we got out there
is that they are developing an Indiana
Jones 5 it keeps getting pushed back but
it has been greenlit last we've checked
as a release date is July 9th 2021
that's from The Hollywood Reporter and
according to Deadline there is a Flash
Gordon reboot that at one point wasn't
had Matthew Vaughn direct now he's just
producing what someone else riding
directing so there those two are
currently in development and it doesn't
seem there's anything for Beetlejuice in
the future currently concrete in
development that's all I could get backs
wise gotcha
please give us your thoughts on this
round this was a really hard one I kept
trying to decide and at the closing
arguments I think I think swayed me I
think the part of its it took me was
between Dan and Christian and the part
of it that got me to be like that would
just be the most interesting reimagining
but the one I would want the most the
thing that like got me the most was the
idea of Tycho being able to really fully
take over Flash Gordon and be able to do
anything I want to not be encumbered by
the things that come from before it so
for that I think Kristen got the point
for me you know that's one for Christian
yeah you know I actually saw it
similarly I
dan gave a good argument and it makes
sense that you know Time Bandits it's
that's a beloved film Oh Beetlejuice
also below film but I don't know I
thought Christian was really hitting on
something
what with we'd want to see a sequel and
Billy I think you know the importance of
Tim Burton's vision there made that film
because I mean Tim Burton's mind in the
80s was just an amazing playground and
that came from there yeah
Billy I I thought you had some great
points about Temple of Doom but at the
end of the day this Flash Gordon you
know sometimes the thing that makes
sense
even the Thor is territory that tyka
was in already that's not the worst
thing in the world and I didn't really
take that as a slight against it I'm a
little disappointed that you did not
mention Ted because yeah I'm a queen
yeah but I got to go with Christian and
Flash Gordon as well Danielle what the
what the poll say the poll is agreed
with 58% for Flash Gordon 30 percent for
Beetlejuice 11 percent for Indiana Jones
in the Temple of Doom other things that
were mentioned Tron Goonies a lot for
he-man Big Trouble in Little China
gremlins monster mutt in the chat I
think had one of my favorite answers
with earth girls are easy I love that
mystery but I would love to see his
version of it and then someone said
electric TR but put into electric
Boogaloo which excuse me that movies
already perfect so there's nothing else
what need we've done to it
yeah when you mentioned he-man within
your argument I was like oh that's
that's a great yeah actually I have very
passionate about the Masters of the
Universe
oh yeah everyone so we are tied Dan with
one Christian with one Billy looking to
get on the board here again at this one
all right this is question number three
here we go
Alamo Drafthouse is planning a
quote-unquote [ __ ] only screening for
the new teen comedy [ __ ] in a good way
so
what movie we ask should have an
exclusive screening like this and who
should be the only people allowed to
attend alright who should be the only
people allowed to attend the special
screening of what movie question three
stars player three how I'm a big guy I
am its truth and you know in Hollywood
they don't want to make they don't want
to make movies about about big people
unless they're there the joke unless
they're the butt of the joke but one
daring man in the 90s mr. Judd Apatow
wrote one of my favorite comedies of all
time 1995 heavyweights I want to see
this movie with my people I want an only
overweight peoples screening of
heavyweights because I know everyone in
that theater it's not awkward you're not
there with your skinny friend like - I
laugh at this does this mean because
obviously the person I'm with is bigger
than me no I am with my own we are
laughing with them we are not laughing
at them we get some of the jokes that
you don't get why am I so sweaty after I
take a nap it's a fat person thing
you're skinny people don't get it I want
to be with my kind when I watch one of
the greatest comedies of all time all
right
silly yes coming out guns blazing with
heavyweights dan my pick is not only a
film screening it is a social experiment
I'm gonna be the best part of it I would
love so much for there to be a screening
where you find the social media people
the YouTube commenters the 200 people in
the world that hated the last Jedi the
most for across the spectrum of reasons
and the only people allowed into the
screening of the last Jedi are those
people and Rian Johnson it is a it is a
stop and start QA screening
we've seen Rian Johnson on social media
he does not back away from a
confrontation or people that don't like
what he does and I very much would like
to see this screening going down with
Rian Johnson at the front of the room
and an open microphone in the aisle
ready to answer any question
that anyone in the room has to ask him I
would pay $500 to sing in the background
and see what happened gonna need more
than that to hire the police it's got a
got to do the entire theater but um
interesting Christian I am I'm going I'm
pretending that the purge is happening
and that laws don't don't mean anything
in my world so I'm saying a screening of
inception but everyone's on acid I think
that to me that is a that is a movie
that again you you will look at that
movie very differently you probably will
look at life very differently for the
rest of your time on this planet and I
think that already you probably the
argument that my two competitors here
will say is that the movie already is on
acid and I think that partially that's
true but I don't know there's something
to me I I don't I don't mind saying and
in college I dabbled in a little bit of
the psychedelics and I think that I
enjoyed I enjoyed touching trees I can
just imagine but watching a Nolan
masterpiece with the Hans Zimmer score
would feel like in a situation like that
so sorry kids that's what this one's all
about
all right fight it out you guys bring
about the acid experience for that one
scene when they're in Paris and the
world foots in on itself and go whoa
music to the music to shore I would like
to bring up that a large part of that
movie is about how there's an evil
person that can be literally anybody and
they are stalking you all the time and
they can be recognized you're taking
acid and one to touch trees the last
thing I need is for my guide next to me
on acid thinking I'm the tree that he
wants to touch someone next to me is
having a bad trip you think if we're
gonna sit in those seats this is why I
like you guys as I know you don't do
drugs it's not what happens on a trip
you know I can be looking around like
that guys gonna get me that guy's gonna
be you gonna be locked into that movie
that it might mean in the classroom
like if I'm going if I'm going to choose
to take acid which I'm not I'm not gonna
take acid but if I were to choose to do
it
inception is it's too heavy I want
something a little bit more fun like
give me the Animatrix at least there's
[ __ ] to get lost in but inception is
kind of drab by design the palettes drab
everything's moving I feel like I'm
gonna have a bad trip no yours yes Luke
Skywalker this is not gonna go the way
you think it is it's gonna go one of two
ways yes whether these trolls are gonna
be silent and it's just gonna be awkward
and that's just not really fun for
anybody or - it's gonna be inglorious
basterds and you lock the doors and you
just set the place on fire and it is a
hate crime he's not gonna being Boreas
best what do you think what do you I'm
see what do you think could happen in
there cuz they Ryan Johnson even with
200 people yes he's good on Twitter but
when you have a bunch off 200 people
scream because I'm telling you I know
I'd host
Jedi Council and I can see there are a
lot of hateful people out there who do
not there a lot of people just outright
don't like the movie but there who hate
it and aid him for it and you stuck the
people the 200 most people that hated
the most that's it you're putting him in
a dangerous position you don't need to
tell me that last Jedi hate cursed
people in a room on acid so don't tell
me about dangerous situations like both
of these are just people watching a
movie yours is I'm Billy I go to a lot
of movies and sure I'll also live in the
United States we're like 75% of the way
there you're screening already just any
normal screening and I'm not the picture
bring it on man I'm saying at least my
movie is a positive experience because
if you've watched heavyweights it
actually is one of the first movies
that's like accept yourself love
yourself but also take some
responsibility for yourself is a great
message and I think so we can all laugh
together it's a positive experience but
we're also getting something out of it
like at least my screening is something
where the photo a legal
B doesn't require millions of dollars of
taxpayers money for police to be there
and it's something positive that the
fans can you can unite for for a movie
that is becoming a cult classic really
like a lot of people love heavyweights
it doesn't get the love that it deserves
but you show it a screening with a bunch
of my fat brethren and and my sisters I
love it I love it but it's a positive
message there's a lot of fat shaming out
there I just did it and what do you want
to share that positive message to people
that maybe you need that person is not
the the message in the movie is
ultimately I don't know how recently
you've seen heavyweights but it's more
about you can't always change them but
you can change you and I think that's an
important message and it's wrapped in
one of the funniest Judd Apatow comedies
that's out there it's Ben Stiller doing
the dodgeball character a thousand times
better before he would do it again ten
years later this is my movie is an
experience that I think would be great
yours scares the [ __ ] out of me yours
could go either be the most boring seven
hours of my life or it could be the most
violent riot that I am either - - and
violent - and violent where I go I'm
just again I say I'm looking at things
just a little differently for those two
hours inside of that Nolan movie for
sure I do think for your you're the one
one point I do think you that's a
positive message in the fact that hey I
feel this way this is how I am come
enjoy the movie with me but I also think
that it's it's one of the it's one of
those things to where maybe I don't know
a lot of people can enjoy that movie
that particular movie it's one thing
when you have hateful people there you
just want those hateful people there you
just want the people there that are just
tripping that one particular time but to
say like well I'm big so I don't want to
be around anybody who's that's small I'm
saying I mean you could say the same
thing about the all-women screening
Wonder Woman that doesn't mean that
other people can't watch it and can't
get something out of it but this is a
chance for the big people to just take a
minute
sit with ourselves laugh at some of the
jokes that it's like we see ourselves
say not feel like we're being judged in
that room not feel like that it's
comfortable because it's moments it's
like ooh can I laugh at that we're with
each other it's one screening one night
I'm not saying other people shouldn't
watch it with yours I don't think the
movies are relevant I think once you're
on acid you can have a fun time with
anything that's not true I disagree I
think that the the Ashley Halloween then
you're gonna be in trouble
the acid part negates the the actual
screening like I don't feel like you
need a screening of anything to kind of
get the same effect that you have yeah
yours
I chose a very strange one because the
thing the thing the problem is is that
by saying the the effects of acid is
that you start to what you think you
think a lot in ways that you never
thought before in that movie Inception
so you're not lost when you're when
you're sitting there and I said you're
locked into this movie you start
thinking and theorizing and doing a lot
more stuff to where you will whether
you're right or wrong you're gonna be
convinced at the very end they whether
or not you know how it definitively ends
that is a movie to me that is this it's
it's a masterpiece I was said it's a
masterpiece and it is a movie that I
don't think you necessarily I'm of
course kidding and I'm okay bowing out
of this one no one should be doing drugs
but it's just as if the fact that you
sitting there tripping balls with the
Nolan with a Nolan movie with the Hans
Zimmer music it's a fun time in college
there's both screenings that where the
headline is people go into movie and
like movie I mean there's these these
special event screenings should be just
that and events and what's the interest
there what's the pool what's the hook
other than we're gonna get a bunch of
people that watch to watch the movie and
like the movie okay that's fine this is
an action you can actually learn
something this is almost an experiment
though it's good obviously there's not
gonna be a murder in the theater though
it's gonna stand up and murder you
why would you want to average more of
that here's the type of behavior that's
the thing though it's not encouraging me
to the behavior if anything I think it's
actually a reality check
easier to Ryan Johnson or the people out
there saying like listen here's this
person that you've crusaded against now
for over a year you have hot fettered
access you can ask him any question that
you want and this is what is fun for
Billy Thank You Dwight and let's go to
Firefox okay I think Dan I get where
you're going for I I see the headline I
would probably run with it myself on sju
but here's the thing
am I going to buy a ticket to go to the
personification of the youtube comment
section no I'm not
we know how toxic how ugly that is
ultimately it would probably be like
Geraldo going into Capone's tomb it
would be you probably get nothing out of
it and it would be a fart in the wind
and it wouldn't matter because you're
right I think a lot of those people are
all bark on line and then you get them
all in a room and it would be either
really boring stopping and starting it
wouldn't be this like massive cultural
societal thing that I think you think it
is and if it was that would be so
irresponsible and so toxic that I would
want nothing to do with that with yours
I still come out of this thing and just
argue to get some I think for for
heavyweights I do think that I think
people underestimate how much people
really do love this movie if you said
that heavyweights was coming back for
like a limited engagement and fat
people's screening come with your your
s'mores and and your camp your camp hope
t-shirts I think people would show up
for it be something positive it would be
something where you could go and you
could feel included in a group I don't
want to be included in that group but I
want to be included in in this group and
I think it would be something good for
everybody thanks Billy Dan I feel like
Bain you say run from the YouTube
section I was born in the darkness Billy
I was shaped by it I am fascinated by it
and I think you say that oh well it's
gonna be toxic it to me whatever I think
it's also perhaps useful is again yes
you have people that have said these
toxic things online when I see stuff
like that when I when I read stuff like
that if it's directed toward me if it's
directed toward you you weave everyone
in this room has had that stuff directed
at them how many times have we have we
said that like if people would just
understand that on the other side of
this screen there is a person that
you're not just yelling at a void like
when you speak to someone online with
that kind of vitriol that you were
talking directly to a person this is the
chance to see that personify to bring in
the people that maybe need to be in that
room to understand that lesson to say
that like okay listen you spent three
months behind the keyboard
saying these things to this guy now the
guys in front of you he's willing to
hear what you have to say and to address
your concerns and if you're not willing
to look him in the eye and say what
you've been saying online for the last
three months maybe that's an important
lesson that they do need to learn maybe
those are the people that you need
because they understand that when they
call this person somebody on Twitter or
they threaten over they talk about
something and then you have to look them
in the eye and you get the chance ask
them the same question maybe they
understand why oh this is this is how
real life works this isn't just an
avatar the only problem is a Ryan where
are we in the fact zone I got one fact
for you it was Al Capone's vault not Al
Capone Al Capone's - that's the only I
had as I did ask around to everyone
Christian knew growing up to confirm if
he's dabbled in psychedelics that's
showing the nacho and there were a lot
of thrown around on how people are an
acid it's hard to check effect on that
one but if it's if they're anything like
my roommate they mostly just ask you to
not leave right on Ryan thank you for
basically giving us nothing all right
but I appreciate your quips
so yeah Christian you had my vote but
then you've no I know I'm kidding there
is such a thing as a bad trip bad trips
are very thing that could be a nightmare
Express or in this life but be fun to
get hot maybe get high and watch
efficient yeah between these two yeah I
thought Billy really nailed it with as
far as like Dan you created like you
said it yourself was interesting social
experiment but the personification of
the youtube comment section is that
gonna be a good thing is gonna be a bad
thing oh I don't know it's kind of
making my mind explode yes the vitriol
and the anger is out of bounds so often
but I mean yeah I don't know it makes my
head spin a little bit but Billy's it
was just a feel-good screening with your
people I thought you defended it so well
when you said just like the Wonder Woman
screening it's not doesn't mean the
movies not for them but it's celebrating
it with people who can
late on that level whenever the movie is
so yeah Billy gets my point Ryan yeah I
felt a similar way with that one I think
the thing with Danny I thought he did a
good job like saying how it would be
useful and cathartic for the people in
that room but to me it still feels like
the most interesting thing about that
screening would be to the people who
work at that screening or the people who
learn something from there whereas I
think what Billy is saying is that it
has the most effect and for the people
actually at that screening which I feel
like fits the spirit of an exclusive
screening that only those people can
attend Billy Budds gets the point
Danielle what the internet say about
acid and some such has a lot to say
about acid I'm glad that were not the
cops I can't guarantee that we aren't
our fans are six your sting operation
screen junkies is a bunch of narc 57%
for heavyweights 28% for Star Wars the
last Jedi 13% for Inception yeah go
check out the movie fights live hash tag
on this there's so many good ones I'm
picking out like one but I could pick
out a million and a lot of really good
ones in the chat as well one was Corinne
underscore W said if I had in my way it
would be a vendor's end game just me oh
not bad yeah you imagine that's better
than it is you don't want to watch it
alone yeah one person was this famous
yeah hmm it's fun to watch a movie and
like on an afternoon sometimes but yeah
Thank You Danielle so this is a great
moment in sports we are tied one to one
to one so we are going to the tiebreaker
this will decide the two combatants that
head to the speed round and the
tiebreaker works dust Li it's very
similar to the speed around so I'm gonna
ask the question shout out your answer
as soon as you got it and then once we
have everyone else everyone's answers
will go in that order that you first
answered and we'll hear you elaborate
for 20 seconds that'll go back around
for a 10-second rebuttal then Danielle
Ryan and myself will decide who does not
move on to the speed round gentlemen
let's do it
tiebreaker question the Mustang a movie
about a convict who bonds with a horse
opens this weekend what's the best movie
about a horse
Seabiscuit got Seabiscuit that's lutely
about a horse I I can think of movies
with horses in them
that's will be about a horse I'm
thinking yeah I'm thinking about horse
whinnies barks Secretariat that was me
yeah there's this in the 70s I think
right the secretary the secretary
Secretariat Secretariat mm-hmm man I'm
gonna be DQ'd by my lack of horse
knowledge I guess I'll have to go black
stallion because that's the only thing
yeah I heard that this table yeah so we
had Seabiscuit from Christian
Secretariat from Dan black stallion from
Billy Christian 20 seconds begin when
you speak well I initially thought of
Secretariat but that was a horse that
just kept winning and the movie was
about a horse that just kept winning and
there's no real story about a horse that
just keeps winning Seabiscuit was Rocky
Seabiscuit was a smaller horse I led by
Toby McGuire who was a smaller guy who
in the depression had had to fight back
from this just it's over you're done in
the depression you're not going anywhere
and get back on the dog store I'm Dan I
think there's a lot more to Secretariat
story than a horse that just kept
winning because didn't come out a winner
this is the horse that made history and
even if you don't like the fact that
they won a lot history is history it's
like saying like oh I watch a movie
about the moon landing they landed on
the moon we all know that no it's about
the journey there it's about the
accomplishments about the achievement
and it's about the fact that it captured
the national imagination and turn people
on to the sport of horse racing in a way
that hadn't been done in decades Billy
both of your movies I'm assuming are
about horse racing which i think is
cruel and terrible and we shouldn't do
that mine is the bot stallion I'm
worshipping the majesticness on my horse
my horse this is about power about
beauty the name is black stallion yours
is Tobey Maguire and he's a Greek yours
was a Maggie Gyllenhaal movie it doesn't
matter because flex ya 10-second bottles
Christian you've never seen that movie
was about a guy like a horse that wasn't
supposed to win that did your movie was
won yes
we wanted to see the story but you
didn't know my horse was gonna win Dan
but my horse is more than just a story
it's about a nation who followed this
horses performance the black stallion is
National Velvet is only there's all kid
in their horse movies there's so many of
them there's only one Secretariat and
there's only one story of this horse and
it's in this movie
Billy kids love horses it's can relate
to your stories they're never gonna be
horse racers but a kid in this horse
it's an age-old story that I probably
would have watched was in kindergarten
War Horse so solid film um Danielle what
do you guys in the speed road to think
so yeah all very compelling horse
arguments but I have to go with the one
where it's very obvious that the person
had not seen her try you really did but
there is horse taking place I love you
Billy you're amazing I will see you at
the fat people screening
Perkis eyes together that's that's one
for Billy I sadly have to agree that fat
but your passions almost got it across
the line but they hedge out win place
show sorry Billy you're not moving on to
the speed round but well fought
throughout I can't today with revenge in
my eye and I didn't have my head in the
game this is what you get this is what
you get Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
sure just throw it out along that day
valiantly fought but Christian and Dan
are moving on to the speed round death
that did not count for a point we are
locked up one one first person to four
will take the point my got that pen
there we go that was good thank you
thank you alright um speed round works
the same as the tiebreak I'll ask the
question call your answers and then
twenty second twenty second ten second
10 second reports movies yes all horse
things darn that was such a joke guys I
could think of 40 of them it's a long
question afterwards is that a joke
please one horse movies did we leave out
hashtag movie fights live all right here
we go question one of the speed round we
are tied 1-1 Lori Loughlin has been
dropped by hallmark what actress because
this whole college scandal what actress
should step up and star in all the
original hallmark movies now the
Hallmark originals good who should step
into the Laughlin boy jennifer Love
Hewitt hmm
jlh
Dame Helen Mirren Dame Helen Mirren yes
all right
we heard Christian first 20 seconds
again we speak I'm going for a second
yeah I jennifer Love Hewitt obviously we
know that she was America's Sweetheart
as she was a teenager coming up she was
just she Justin captured everything
about you you loved her so why not step
into these Hallmark now she has she has
children she's a mom she has shown that
she's versatile and she is squeaky clean
there is no scandal with jennifer Love
Hewitt's she's perfect for these roles
plus she's not in a lot of movies put
her in these movies damn just for Love
Hewitt fits into the same mold though
you have Lacey Chabert Lori Loughlin
people that were in on TV in the
eighties and nineties and they gon do
hallmark movies I want to see what Dame
Helen Mirren brings to the bakery owner
who falls in love with the prince and
the seamstress who falls in love with
the prince and the illustrator who falls
in love with the prince
and all the other falls in love with the
prince hallmark movies get a little
prestige come on they're cookie cutter
they're a laughingstock
give it some act if you were an
executive at Hallmark I would fire you
because Mirren would cost way too much
money Jennifer love you it is attainable
go and get her and people like
comfortability they don't like change go
and get jlh go and get jlh and blend in
on to the rest of them everyone's
starting a streaming service nowadays
you got a differentiation what better
way to elevate the hallmark movies in
the must-see status than by giving one
of the most legendary actors of our time
Dame Helen Mirren and I'd love to see
you open all right
the the Dame versus jlh Ryan
yeah I think I'm gonna have to go down
that first one I felt like most of the
things against Helen debt that Christian
was trying to put out there didn't
really hold with me and I think that one
was the clearest image of like what
would be the most exciting thing for
lifetime so I'm gonna go down on this I
got to disagree with you I feel like it
was a too much of a shock to the system
people don't like change I agree with
Christian you want to just plop someone
in to make the goddamn same hallmark
movies that someone's eaten and even
scoops of ice cream on this on a
Saturday night to get away their sorrows
so yeah I'm going Christian on that
Danielle all right well breaking the tie
you know anything again these are
completely wildly different answers both
very great
you're right Jo late she is very sweet
clean she is America's Sweetheart and
she was at one time I don't think that
saying that someone is attainable is
necessarily a compliment and I'm not
gonna lie I've seen because I think
Jennifer Love Hewitt has done some of
those movies I would like to see Helen
Mirren fall in love with a Baker Prince
or however he praised it
that's how did we're exciting to me
especially when talking about streaming
there are already a bunch of Prince
movies on on Netflix so give me some of
that good good Helen Mirren going with
Dan all right Dan gets the point um Dan
takes a 2-1 lead in the droughts
lifetime what's that my dad loves
Lifetime movies I love I think there's a
secret dad demo for that there is yeah
there definitely is right on all right
comment if you are part of that secret
dad demo of lifetime and hallmark movies
question number two dan is up two to one
in honor of Avengers endgame what's the
best final movie and a franchise Return
of the King Return of the King
pritu we have Return of the King we have
Creed to Dan you spoke first 20 seconds
we can we speak first of all we don't
know the Creed 2 is gonna be the final
movie and the Creed franchise they could
very easily go with Kerr 3 Eid coming in
2022 but I think loathing under King had
the weight of expectation had the weight
of wrapping up a 3 movie long epoch and
did it so well that it won best picture
it end in a high note and how many
franchises can you say the final movie
was the one that got the most acclaimed
the most Awards the most from fans they
didn't screw it up and usually movies on
this Creek pritu didn't rap created
wrapped Rocky it was thought it was the
whole point of that it was it was
supposed to be how that fight damaged
rocky how much it did to his his
marriage his son everything and you saw
it all come back and it happened with
the guy that he lost and it was a
redemption for Rocky it wrapped up the
entire Rocky story not necessarily just
Creed with the rocky story itself creed
4 excuse me Creed too wrapped up rocky
the entire franchise and I thought did
it very did it brilliantly I still think
we're TBD on that it wasn't called Rocky
9 it was called Creed 2 the Creed
franchise may continue and how many
times have we seen a franchise retire a
character only to bring him back out for
the next one Lord of the Rings wrapped
up the trilogy and wrapped it up
magnificently
I mean Lord of the Rings definitely
followed the book but I thought what the
film was able to do was take a series of
films and like I said he had wrapped up
the rocky franchise was it the question
with as far as the franchise goes they
wrapped it up Stallone had a big arc
throughout this entire thing had to just
soak with Creed and finished it time
okay
yeah I thought Christian made a really
compelling argument for Creed 2 but Dan
really just brought out the you know
brought out that Oscar gold and I felt
like he painted that epic picture for
Return of the King I'm going with Dan
and The Return of the King
Danielle yet I do agree what they were
both compelling but I have degree I
thought the dance Oscar argument was
stronger as well as saying you don't
necessarily know and it's a little
pedantic we don't necessarily know that
this is gonna be the last Creed so I
gotta go with them all right Dan takes
the point dan has a 3-1 lead this is
game point Christian you need this one
to keep her going
here we go we got a trailer this week
for Warner Brothers animations animated
team-up Batman versus the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles what character facing off
against the Ninja Turtles would make the
best movie two character characters of
his character singular what comparator
okay
pass five for John wick three robocop oh
hey I will not be biased okay we heard
John wick first Dan
twenty seconds when you speak I think
the ninja is what they don't really lean
you some teenage Ninja Turtles too much
so I'd love to see them actually have to
use these powers of deception and escape
against the the Baba Yaga who's
practically a ninja himself this this
this one man who can take down a huge
squat against these these turtles that
have to rely on deception to get away a
four-on-one with the nunchucks and
swords just a four on one John wick
fight with the circle yeah it'd be fun
to watch them fight against John wick
short but I see them do karate all the
time how they gonna battle Robocop
coming out with a bunch of gun with it
with his guns and his and his the
equipment that he has technology how are
they gonna fight that they use their
head they're smart they'd be funny to
see him get slapped in the face of the
pizza and he can't see out of his visor
and he's trying to figure it out then
the rat kicks him in the nuts gonna be
he'd be good to watch I'm done how do
you fight Robocop four syllables
Donatello he knows machines that's what
he does he's big he's slow three am I
gonna hold down Robocop Donatella's
gonna disable him and that's a that's
the end of the fight John wick you're
gonna get a great fight scene there
gonna be a cat and mouse and turtle the
whole movie I just seen it I've seen him
do the karate I don't want to see that
anymore I want to see how they're able
to fight this techni technological
terror if you will how are they gonna do
it how are they gonna fight him what are
they gonna the back-and-forth dialogue
still will be amazing
alright Ryan what do you got wolf that
one was a tough one I swung back and
forth I think I'm gonna go Christian on
this one I thought he made a good point
with the action of that would be
interesting to see them face off against
something more robotic instead of doing
the karate and he kind of also you know
made sure that we know we would still
get the comedy you know I kind of stuff
of messing with a more serious character
so I go Christian right on let's go to
the other half of ride and dirty
Daniel Radford yeah I have to say
agree with Ryan I really like to say I
agree I'm sorry okay Christian you are
still in the game it is three to two you
need this one to tie it's still game
point mr. Murrell here we go that's how
it does machines by the way I know
that's gonna I know I mean if people
could take that a certain way um here it
is question for the speed around Noah
Holly's Doctor Doom project is in limbo
right now who would you most want to see
play Doctor Doom Michael Fassbender
Christoph Waltz okay we got Fassbender
we got Waltz Christian we heard you
first 20 seconds when you speak Michael
Fassbender has shown with his portrayal
of magneto that he can make villains
complex he can make you feel for them
the way that I wanted a feel for Anakin
Skywalker I felt for magneto in those
initial movies I want to feel that for
Doctor Doom I want to see what's gonna
happen with Doctor Doom and how the or
he's as much of the origin story with
the Fantastic Four as the actual
Fantastic Four and I think Michael
Fassbender an actor like that has shown
he can play a hero and as shown he can
play a complex villain and I'd like to
see him do a little bit more sass
Fassbender take on two huge villains in
the same stable and Doctor Doom and
magneto first I think it's a little too
se me secondly Michael Fassbender does
tortured but what I think you need to
bring to Doctor Doom is something that
Christoph Waltz can have which is that
he has that kind of European vibe but he
also can be both cartoonish and sinister
at the same time you saw that an
inglorious basterds he brings that
energy so that he's over-the-top but
also your reason for him is my reason
against him I think he's too cartoony
I've seen him play villain so many
different times that I'm just I can
predict what he's gonna do how he's
gonna be everything that he's done in
every bond in a Bond movie but he's done
it before and I've seen it I want these
other more complex and I've seen Michael
Fassbender play the evil a big bad of
the franchise I want to see some of that
Hans Landa energy where you love him but
you also hate him and he brings that
villainy to it he's sinister and
cartoonish and a villain he could play
all those parts oh man
well what a throwdown like I was back
and forth trading blows this was it's
just like this is like if much of what
tie as I've ever seen in like a speed
round question damn it you guys by the
hair of his chinny chin chin I gotta go
Dan just buy it
Oh barely Ryan yeah this was tough for
me as well it's going back and forth I
think Kristin kind of invalidated a
little he said when he used the top of
his argument saying you've seen Michael
Fassbender done this before and then
saying that you don't want Christoph
because we've seen it before I think
that was a little bit of the edge where
then Dan had the best image of how he
would fit for a Doctor Doom character
about the cartoonish Ness and the in the
evilness and I thought I went with Dan
as well Dan Moreau just one movie fights
Chris Joe well fought furious come back
there and man that last question it was
just like it made my head explode for a
moment there's no wrong guys yeah Dan
well played
please give some thoughts and shoutouts
and the game it's a fun game to play I
like just to do it discipline
mm-hmm III people seem to get mad now
win them so I'm sorry I want people to
enjoy the show
hey death taxes and Dan were awaiting a
movie fights but Dan well fought and
nicely done I mean it's just like the
way you parry and move in that speed
around it's fun to watch also fun to
watch Christian you you really brought
it today and it was it was great and you
also brought something else speaking of
the Schmo down earlier yeah I was
talking to Billy and Dan about before
and if I could show you guys a little
bit about what we're doing on March 23rd
we are doing the free-for-all it is 40
competitors I showed a little teaser
here and I give it a JT
ladies and gentlemen it's time for the
40 competitors going at it who's gonna
be the last person standing five
competitors will start at the table
people who have the lowest amount of
points on the desk will be eliminated
and that new competitors will enter you
never know who's coming down the ramp
max you guys can be there to watch it
all go down in downtown La Forge on
Oxford Wow
not missed head to head to head to head
to figure out who is the ultimate
champion here
[Music]
this is something special
oh how about it man
yeah that really gets you going mr.
Schmo down live.com you can see it
downtown LA please come and check it out
you might see him you might not you
might see a bunch of different people so
come and check it out it's gonna be a
lot of fun yeah free-for-all is great
times and to be there live that energy
in the room is off the charts Christian
very cool Congrats and thank you again
for being here in your great fights
Billy biz you had some great answers
yourself and like I think you touched a
lot of people out there with that with
yo with your third round yeah tell us so
where we can find you in LA you can
probably find me on my when I challenge
for the all horse inter geekdom time oh
yeah that's great and we'll get to the
bottom who came up with that question
Ryan thank you so much for holding it
down the fact zone yeah awesome then my
best and it'll be better next time I
promise there may not be a next thing no
that was great that was excellent thank
you sir and Daniel Radford the other
half of the classic combo a ride and
dirty I just can't stop saying that
thank you for being just wonderful and
delightful please tell them where they
can find you same places as usual you
can find me on twitter at daniel Radford
oh if any of you are going to WonderCon
I'm going to be on the most dangerous
women panel some of the info for that is
on my Twitter so come check it out heck
yeah and I want to thank you for
watching movie fights I'm Hal Rudnick on
the Twitter's and the instagrams yeah
come check me out there and I'll say a
lot of stupid stuff about movies TVs and
whatnots and I want to plug the show
real quick this weekend if you are in
Los Angeles come to the UCB Franklin
Theatre The Upright Citizens Brigade
Saturday March 16th at midnight for the
tournament of nerds it is going to be
quite a throwdown a pop culture roast
battle more or less so that's always a
good time thanks everybody Dan well
played everybody great stuff Billy
Thank You jte thank you and yeah we'll
see you next time bye-bye